at some point in your life
when you were outside on a clear dark
night
did you ever look up at the stars
and wonder
do any of those stars have planets
are they anything like the planets in
our solar system
are there any other worlds just like the
earth
and are there any creatures on those
planets looking back at me wondering the
same thing
people have been asking these questions
throughout history
ever since we realized that all those
tiny points of light in the sky
are stars like the sun
just much farther away
this helps explain why the field of
exoplanets the study of planets that
orbit distant stars
has attracted so much attention
for the same reason
exoplanetary science is usually
portrayed in the media and in public
lectures and even in college classrooms
as a single-minded quest for other
planets like the earth
the kinds of planets that might support
life
the search for earth 2.0
and this is certainly one of the fields
most exciting aspects
but it's not the only thing that i'm
looking forward to sharing with you in
these lectures
the truth is that while we astronomers
have been making steady progress on
finding another earth
some of the most remarkable discoveries
have been planets with unexpected and
very unearth-like properties
planets unlike any of the planets that
we find in our own solar system
for example
did you know we found an earth-sized
planet that goes around its sun
once every eight hours
so it completes three of its years in
every one of our days
did you know that we found planets that
orbit backward compared to the rotation
of the stars that they orbit
did you know that we found planets that
orbit around two different suns
sort of like luke skywalker's home
planet of tatooine
or switching from star wars to star trek
we really are exploring strange new
worlds just like the mission of the
starship enterprise
during our time together you will learn
how we search for planets around other
stars
and why it's so difficult
you'll get a complete briefing on this
brand new field that only really got
going in the 1990s
we'll discuss the new technologies that
allowed us to make these discoveries
what kinds of planets we found
and how close we really are to finding
truly earth-like planets
you'll come away with a solid
physics-based understanding of this
exciting realm of astronomy
i'd like to start with the question of
why we study exoplanets why is this
field attracting so much public
attention and so much research funding
why are young scientists flocking to
this area
why did i switch fields
dropping my earlier research on
measuring the expansion rate of the
universe to devote my effort to studying
planets around other stars
well there are lots of reasons
and i'm going to give you five
the first one is simple
exploration
basic human curiosity about what's out
there
we know that we live around a star
that's part of a much larger galaxy and
we've gotten to know our home here in
the solar system
so what else is out there
it's the same impulse that sent marco
polo to china captain cook to australia
and the apollo astronauts to the moon
we want to explore
other worlds
with different atmospheres a different
strength of gravity a different type of
star in the sky
a second reason
is a more specific kind of exploration
the search for life
the yearning to know whether there are
other planets like earth and whether or
not we are alone
as we'll see the search for life
elsewhere in the universe is going to be
a long journey it might take a decade or
a generation maybe even centuries
there's so much that we still need to
learn about how life got started on the
earth and about how we might recognize
it on another planet and what kinds of
telescopes or other machines we're going
to need to build to conduct the search
but what's exciting is that we've taken
the first few steps on that journey
we're right at the threshold of finding
other planets similar to the earth
and there are projects underway to take
the next steps
if we can do it
if we can overcome all the obstacles and
find an unambiguous sign of life on
another planet
well that would be one of the most
significant discoveries in all of human
history
now
those are reasons to study exoplanets
that i think appeal to everyone at some
level but honestly they're not the only
reasons or even the main reasons why so
many young scientists are getting into
this field there are other attractions
which appeal even to scientists who
would never admit to being a starry-eyed
explorer or wanting to find e.t
one of those attractions and the third
reason to study exoplanets
is the rich physics problem of planet
formation
where do planets come from
they didn't just spring into existence
at the beginning of the universe
somehow
all of the tiny specks of dust in the
vicinity of a star managed to accumulate
into a giant sphere
how does that happen
how can we explain all the patterns that
we see in the solar system
in this course we'll learn about the
prevailing theory of planet formation
and how it's been challenged and changed
by the discoveries of weird new types of
planets
now i also have a lot of colleagues who
might like the physics problem of planet
formation but what they really love is
building new and improved machines for
measuring starlight
that's the fourth reason to study
exoplanets the technological challenge
observing exoplanets is one of the most
difficult jobs in astronomy which
motivates us to invent ambitious and
creative solutions
as we'll see
we've come up with a lot of different
techniques for finding exoplanets based
on a wide range of different principles
of physics
these range from basic freshman level
physics
detecting the motion of stars and
planets as they pull on each other with
the force of gravity
to more exotic theories such as
einstein's theory of general relativity
and in all those cases
the signals we're trying to detect are
minuscule and elusive
detecting them requires exquisite
engineering
and often a lot of money
all of the billion dollar telescopes
that are being planned for the future
including the successors to the hubble
space telescope are being designed
specifically with exoplanets in mind
and finally there's a more personal
reason why i love studying exoplanets
it's so satisfying to work in a field
that the public understands and
appreciates
everybody learns about the planets of
the solar system in school
everyone sees the stars and the planets
in the night sky
and everyone wonders what other planets
might be like
so i can go into my son's 4th grade
classroom and explain exactly what i'm
doing and why and they all get it
they go home and they tell their parents
and their grandparents and they get it
too
this is not the case for my colleagues
who work in more esoteric realms of
physics
who study the higgs boson or the
fractional quantum hall effect
now this is not to say exoplanetary
science is more important than those
other subjects
just that it has an extra reward it's
easier for the public to cheer us on and
even to get involved in our work
now
let's get down to business
we're going to be spending a lot of time
exploring strange new worlds so let's
start by giving ourselves a baseline
let's remind ourselves of the basic
properties of our solar system
so that when we do encounter those weird
and wonderful exoplanetary systems
will have a good basis for comparison
until the mid-1990s the only planets we
knew about were the ones that go around
the sun
mercury venus earth mars
jupiter saturn uranus neptune
and then
well there's pluto
pluto was once thought of as a planet
but now we understand it to belong to a
different category from the others
it's just one of many similar small
objects that reside in the so-called
kuiper belt
it's a more distant version of the
asteroid belt that exists between the
orbits of mars and jupiter
now when you were in the fourth grade
you probably had to learn the names of
the planets
maybe you even made a model of the solar
system or saw one at a science museum
well let's relive that experience now
and have some fun constructing a scale
model for the solar system
it's going to be a model in which the
sizes of the sun and the planets and the
distances between them
will all be in the correct proportions
they'll all be scaled down by the same
factor of 800 million
i chose 800 million
because that brings things down to a
more familiar human scale
if we shrink the sun
down by a factor of 800 million
it'll have a diameter of 5 foot 8 about
as tall as i am
so i want you to imagine that the sun
this giant hot glowing ball of hydrogen
and helium
is my size
now
let's look at each planet starting with
the innermost planet mercury
it's an airless ball of rock and iron
with lots of craters a lot like our
familiar moon
and on the scale of our model
mercury is going to be the size of
a pomegranate seed
only about a quarter of an inch across
so lesson one planets are much smaller
than stars
this holds for exoplanets too and it's
what makes detecting exoplanets so
difficult
at this point we've only managed to
detect one really secure case of an
exoplanet as small as mercury
the next planet in our solar system is
venus
venus is also a rocky planet but unlike
mercury venus has a thick atmosphere of
carbon dioxide which blankets the
surface and causes it to heat up to over
850 degrees fahrenheit
it's an exaggerated version of the
greenhouse effect that we're concerned
about here on the earth
venus also has clouds made of sulfuric
acid
so even though the ancient greeks and
romans saw venus as the goddess of love
with all that fire and brimstone it's
really more like the traditional concept
of hell
for our model i should really be using a
hot coal coated with acid
but let's keep things simple and use a
grape
earth needs no introduction and it's
always a pleasure to look at pictures of
our home planet taken from space
interestingly earth and venus are
essentially twins when it comes to size
and mass
they're both made mainly of rock and
iron
so for our model
we'll use a grape for the earth
now as we'll see
for most exoplanets
all we know about the planet is its
diameter and mass which means that venus
and earth which are in reality two very
different worlds would appear to be
identical if they were both orbiting
some distant star
that's a limitation of our knowledge
about exoplanets that's worth
remembering
next is mars the red planet
have you ever seen it in the sky when it
makes its closest approach to the earth
it's fun to watch that red point of
light move through the constellations as
the weeks go by
up close our spacecraft and rovers have
explored the surface and revealed
landscapes of orange brown rocks
mountains and dried up river valleys
it's another rocky planet like venus and
earth though it's a bit smaller
in our scale model
mars is going to be a cranberry
continuing outward the next planet is
jupiter a behemoth made mainly of
hydrogen and helium gas
the gases rotate around in distinct
bands of latitude
occasionally getting swirled up into
storms most famously the great red spot
to be on the same scale as our sun and
the inner four planets jupiter is going
to be nearly seven inches across
size of a cantaloupe
but remember there's no solid surface on
jupiter really we should be using a
self-gravitating ball of gas
but i couldn't find one at the grocery
store
around other stars we found lots of
gaseous exoplanets as large as jupiter
and even larger in fact as we'll see
we've found these giant planets in the
strangest places where we didn't expect
them
that brings us to saturn another gas
giant but this one with a dazzling set
of rings going around the planet
nasa's cassini spacecraft is currently
orbiting saturn delivering breathtaking
views of those rings
someday i hope we'll be able to detect
rings around exoplanets too
but we don't have any way of sending
spacecraft to exoplanets and making
these sorts of detailed images for the
moment we have to be content with
knowing the sizes of exoplanets their
masses the shapes of their orbits
and some characteristics of their
atmospheres as we'll see
coming back to our scale model of the
solar system saturn is going to be a
grapefruit a grapefruit with rings
and finally we have the planets uranus
and neptune
these are sort of in between the rocky
and gaseous planets they both have
substantial amounts of solid material
rock and iron but they also have lots of
hydrogen and helium as well as other
lightweight molecules such as water
methane and ammonia
and they don't have solid surfaces
either instead if you could travel
inside them you'd first find yourself
surrounded by gas
then as you descend and the pressure
increases the atmosphere will become
more like a liquid which gets denser and
denser and gradually becomes solid
uranus and neptune are nearly twins too
when it comes to size and mass
so the solar system has two sets of
twins
but instead of being a pair of grapes
like earth and venus uranus and neptune
are bigger
in our model they're plums
later in this course we'll see that the
most common type of exoplanet known
today has a size in between that of
earth and neptune
these are the so-called super earths or
mini neptunes
okay
now we've got all our planets on the
right scale
sun is as big as i am
and the planets are a pomegranate seed
two grapes cranberry cantaloupe a
grapefruit and two plums
so
where are we gonna put all this fruit
we need to space them out so that the
distances between them are on the same
scale as their sizes
here we have a problem
the distances are vast
even after shrinking down the sizes of
their orbits by a factor of 800 million
we're going to need more room than we
have in this studio
a lot more
to help us visualize and comprehend
these distances let's imagine that i'm
taking a walk in a place that might be
familiar to many of you manhattan in new
york city
i'll start in times square with all
these fruits in my backpack
and while i'm walking i'll drop off each
planet at the appropriate distance
first i walk along broadway from 46th to
47th street about one block north that's
where i drop mercury
already you see the solar system is very
spread out
you've got a person-sized sun at one end
of the block
and all the way at the other end is a
pomegranate seed representing mercury
then i keep walking north about three
quarters of the block that's where i
drop one of our two grapes representing
venus
to get to earth's orbit i need to keep
walking until i've gone a total of just
over two and a half blocks
so i'm between 48th and 49th streets now
i can set down the grape representing
our home planet
and when i look back at the sun in times
square
it looks small
i can cover it up with a dime when i
hold it out at arm's length that's the
same size the actual sun looks to us in
our sky
after that pause
i keep walking north until i've gone a
total of four blocks
where i set down our cranberry mars
i'm feeling pretty good at this point
i've laid down half the planets in just
five minutes of walking
but now it's time to get serious
to reach the distance of jupiter's orbit
and unload this heavy cantaloupe i need
to walk almost 10 more blocks
so i pass carnegie hall and i'm just
about to reach central park about six
tenths of a mile from the sun in times
square
but i'm not done
i keep walking straight into the park
until i'm more than a mile from where i
started where i can lay down the
grapefruit saturn
and get a drink at the tavern on the
green
so i'm feeling refreshed and my load is
lighter now
but i'm not even halfway done with my
walk
uranus and neptune are much more remote
to get to uranus's orbit i need to walk
another 1.1 miles to the very northern
end of central park
and neptune might be uranus's twin in
size and mass but it's not right next
door to get to neptune i need to leave
central park and walk up into harlem up
to around 138th street
bringing my total distance to three and
a half miles
that's where i drop the second
plumb and suddenly i'm relieved that
pluto is not a planet because if it were
i would have needed to walk another mile
to get there
all the way up to yankee stadium and i'm
already pretty wiped out
while i'm resting let's reflect on this
exercise
we've imagined a scale model of a solar
system in which the entire earth
is the size of a grape
and the true distance from the earth to
the sun of 93 million miles
maps onto 600 feet in our model
we've seen how spread out the solar
system is
how small the planets are relative to
the sun
and how different the sizes of the
planets are relative to each other
ranging from a pomegranate seed to a
cantaloupe
one thing to keep in mind is that
although we imagined i was walking in a
straight line and putting the planets
down along that line
in reality the planets are all at
different angles in their orbits
so they're usually in what look like
random locations along the circles of
their orbits
it takes a special coincidence for even
three of them to line up and you'd never
see all eight of them right along a
straight line
even to find all the planets in the same
quadrant of the solar system within 90
degrees of each other is rare it happens
once every 120 years on average
and even more importantly
i want you to be aware of three striking
patterns in the solar system which will
be essential to keep in mind as we study
exoplanets
first of all
the planets go around the sun in orbits
that are very nearly circles
mercury's orbit makes a little circle
that's inside of venus's larger circle
which is inside of earth's circle and so
on
what's interesting about this is that
there's no law of physics that says the
orbits must be circles
more generally the laws of physics say
that orbits are elliptical
they can range anywhere from circles to
extremely elongated narrow ovals
so it's remarkable that the orbits of
all eight planets in the solar system
are nearly perfect circles
the second pattern is that all the
circles
are aligned with each other they all lie
flat in a single plane
like different grooves in a record
for those of you like me who are old
enough to remember what a record looks
like
that's why we were able to make our
scale model on flat ground
i didn't need to climb any stairs or
tall buildings or mountains thank
goodness before putting down the planets
and by the way
that single plane is also aligned with
the equator of the sun so all the
planets are revolving in the same way
the sun is rotating
so the solar system seems like a nice
tidy well-aligned system
the third pattern has to do with the
sizes of the planets
all the little planets
mercury venus earth mars are close to
the sun
and all the big planets jupiter saturn
uranus neptune are much farther away
this is unlikely to be a coincidence
it's almost as though the planets were
neatly sorted
so what was it that caused the little
rocky planets to be so much closer in
than the giant gaseous planets
these three patterns have long been
regarded as clues about the formation of
the solar system and by extension the
formation of planets anywhere in the
universe
and like i said earlier one of the
reasons we study exoplanets is that we
want to see if the patterns that exist
in the solar system
the circular well-aligned orbits with
the small planets inside and the large
planets outside
are universal patterns
or just provincial
fine so to prepare to study exoplanets
let's go back to where we left off in
our walk through manhattan and continue
walking to reach the exoplanets
where is the nearest exoplanet
as we'll see later in this course
there's evidence
decent evidence not completely secure
for a small rocky planet around one of
the closest stars to the sun a star
named alpha centauri b
which shines brightly in the southern
hemisphere in the constellation of
centaurus
so now that i've had a chance to rest
let's walk over there
well the problem is alpha centauri b
is very far away in our scale model
i would have to keep walking
all the way across new york and
connecticut
and way beyond in fact to get to alpha
centauri i'd end up walking 32 000 miles
that's a distance 30 percent longer than
the circumference of the entire earth
so you see the distances between planets
in the solar system might be big
but the distances to even the nearest
stars are stupendously greater
even though we shrank everything down by
a factor of 800 million to try and make
things more familiar we still end up
with astronomical distances between
stars so large
that they're hard to comprehend
but let's just imagine i could somehow
walk for 32 000 miles
and arrive at alpha centauri b the very
nearest exoplanet
what would i see when i get there
what i would see is not just one star
but a trio of stars alpha centauri is a
triple star system
with two stars orbiting one another and
a third little star further out that
orbits around both of the bigger stars
the biggest star is alpha centauri a
it's a little bigger than the sun
in our model it would be six foot eleven
so like a professional basketball player
and then there's alpha centauri b
a smaller orange star about five feet
tall and the third distant star proxima
centauri is a cute little red star about
10 inches across
so you see stars can have a wide range
of sizes too
and
around that orange medium-sized star
alpha centauri b
would be a little grape-sized planet
that's the nearest exoplanet for which
we currently have any evidence
now remember in this scale model the
earth was a couple of city blocks away
from the sun
but the amazing thing about alpha
centauri b
is that its planet is much closer
it's only 24 feet away it would fit
right in the studio
so that's our first sighting of
something really different about
exoplanetary systems they can have
planets that are much closer to their
stars
than any of our planets are to the sun
but you might be asking yourself
how can we possibly know anything about
planets in the alpha centauri system
all our planets are packed into
manhattan
and to get to the nearest exoplanet i
had to travel a distance
more than all the way around the earth
looking back toward the sun
we would be hard pressed to see anything
at all
let alone the little grapes and the
other fruits that we dropped
so how in the world can we actually
study the planets that go around other
stars given how astonishingly far away
even the very nearest stars are from the
sun
well stay tuned that's exactly what
we'll discuss in the next two lectures
[Music]
you